for days nothing has happened the brave
turn remains moored in the harbor leak
hello is fed up he wants to get working
that's why he went into the offshore
industry I've done maybe sixteen years
operating cranes and then I got bored of
sitting in one place too long and just
fancied a change so I've come into lifts
and supervisor and a lot of rigging work
and stuff like that but the weather is
not cooperating it's too windy
we've been waiting now for that that's
before days three four days until you
arrived at this Harbor yesterday but
death we were arriving the last harbor
waiting there for two or three days as
well so but weather doesn't look good
for the next few days so we're just
trying to keep ourselves occupied the
rotor with its blades spanning more than
100 metres has to be loaded on board but
it's extremely sensitive to wind loading
will have to wait yet another day take
the Machine down poles both sides of
each blade there will come down the
sides of the blades just inspected for
damage any big scratches at it paint
damage that could have been done to an
installation
we'll just take an extra care this time
the brave turn is the jakab installation
vessel built especially to help
construct offshore wind turbines every
day the ship and its crew cost 150,000
euros even when they're sitting idle for
a year now PRP cutoff skis workplace has
been on the brave turns bridge
he's the ship's second mate the person
who is responsible for all navigation
equipment all radio equipment and he has
to keep an eye on the wind speed until
Monday no chance
the weather limit is above the limit we
have got the limit 6 and 8 meter per
second for boat rotors so unfortunately
we have to wait for the better water the
offshore wind power business requires a
boatload of patience while the ship's
crew tends to some maintenance the
Constructors have an enforced break
even when they're not working they
receive full pay but just sitting around
is draining nonetheless oh you can Lewis
think about your family back home and
girlfriend boyfriend's going out and
socializing and still feel the outsider
doing nothing
finally the weather changes the wind has
died down it's time to get going
leek hello and his installation crew are
supposed to maneuver to complete wind
turbines onto the ship and secure them
loading just one component has already
taken two hours
at 6:00 in the evening the night shift
takes over the work continues non-stop
20 hours later Kelo has the last part
loaded on board the workers are from
Britain Ireland Denmark and Germany
they've been working together since last
December
Layton's first the guys are going now to
ready to lift the gangway the land the
gangway back on the key side the doctors
will release it for us and then we'll
start floating
on the bridge everyone is highly focused
P kotovsky wears his official uniform
his boss the captain steers the ship out
of the port 170 metres long 100 metres
wide 660 deep 61 people on board into
the raging North Sea P kotovsky has
studied navigation he wants to become a
captain himself always dependent from
from from the captain especially because
he is like you know the main person who
can say that you are ready for the next
promotion or not and from from yourself
if you feel that you have enough
experience and you feel that can you can
go higher than that's the best time
after a week the brave turn is finally
out in the open sea speed is 11 knots
destination 180 kilometres away
in the middle of the night they're close
to their goal the job at the wind park
begins we'll have more in the next
episode